our mind is the control tower of our
life
whatever happens in our life starts
right here now I don't think you should
ever live to the point you think well
I've reached it now then what do you do
you just die evil don't realize that
money is dangerous somebody says well
what could be dangerous about money
it's what it does hello believe nation
I'm Evan Carmichael my one word is
believe and I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of the world's
major problems so to help you on your
journey today we're going to learn from
Pastor Charles Stanley and my take on
his top ten rules of success rule number
three is my personal favorite and I'd
love to know which one you guys like the
best and as always as you're listening
if something really resonates with you
there's a message that really holds true
to you please leave it down the comments
below and put it in quotes so that other
people can be inspired and when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well enjoy
a person who's willing to just take it
easy do whatever comes natural don't
have any real goals in life don't strive
for anything and I think part of the
reason that is that people are lazy they
want the easy way out
they don't believe that they can
accomplish anything in life they don't
have a sense of purpose
they have no goals they don't know how
to set goals in their life and what they
do is they waste a great deal of their
life because they have no sense of
direction and they just settle for
whatever comes their way and oftentimes
thinking that they can't do any better
and looking around what other people are
doing and thinking well I'm as good as
they are and they miss life settling for
less than the best why do you think so
many people do that why are they so
willing to settle for less than God's
best what they they don't really believe
that they can achieve and accomplish
they look around and see what other
people are doing and they think well I'm
as well off as there but that's not the
issue the issue is what is the will of
God for my life
what could I accomplish what could I
achieve if I really enjoy this said my
mind to do it and I think sometimes it's
just pure laziness that people don't
have a sense of direction
but they don't want to do anything else
and it's a tragedy that a person can
live out their life with the gifts and
skills and abilities and talents and
God's given them and just settle for
doing whatever it comes natural what are
some of the warning signs that we are
living a settled for life okay number
one there's no progress in life not
making any progress financially in
relationships in your layin ship to the
Lord
things are just sort of status quo and
you're sort of running around in circles
and spending time and living from one
weekend after to the other and I think
people who do that they've settled for
far less than God has intended for them
well God wants us all to be courageous
because he knows we'll face times in
life in situations and circumstances
that it takes more than just a desire
takes courage
many people operate on the basis of fear
on the basis what other people think we
as believers should operate on the basis
of courage courage to say no when we
ought to say no courage to say yes when
we should say yes so what kind of
courage that you have is you're sort of
floating between depending on the
situation or do you know the difference
between right and wrong for your life
and you've made up your mind our mind is
the control tower of our life whatever
happens in our life starts right here
all of our decisions of air and the
truth is whatever we are today is the
result of what we've been thinking about
all those years the Bible says as a man
thinketh in his heart so is he
so if you don't like what's going on
around you maybe you should ask yourself
the question what am I thinking about
what do I think about myself what I
think about other people because what we
think about is really what controls us
for example our relationship to God our
relationship to each other a sense of
direction in life whatever we
accomplished as failures in life all of
that is a result of the way we think and
oftentimes we forget that that this is a
control tower that everything else is a
result of how we think and we can't
control everybody else in control of all
of our circumstances but we are going to
respond to circumstances in one way or
the other and so when I think about how
this affects us I think about the fact
that many people of where they are
because of wrong thinking and so they
don't like where they are other folks
are where they are because of right
thinking because they've been thinking
the right way what you have to ask is
this what is it that determines what I
think this this mind abuse controls
everything else in your life you say
well what about all the other parts of
my life we respond to the way we think
and so if we think right we're going to
have one response we think wrongly we're
going to have another very important
that we understand
how that works so this requires me to
understand how to control my thoughts if
I want to think right if I want to thank
God me if I want to paint hole if I want
to think righteously right here's where
it starts and many people lose it right
here
they don't think right they don't think
godly they don't think like they're
worth anything and they say well you
know I just never had the opportunity or
I just never will be that or I'm just
this and I'm not that this is why people
who are very beautiful can think they're
ugly and people who are very skinny can
think they're fat and they refuse to eat
because they think they look in the
mirror and they don't see what's reality
and so your mind controls every aspect
of your life in fact what you think
determines how you live what do you
think determines has your relationship
to God as we said relationship to others
your relationship to yourself and many
people start out in life defeated
because of the influence of their
parents their grandparents that tell
them they'll never amount to anything
all this is wrong with them well that's
wrong with them and as a result they go
to her life what having heard written in
their minds impressed in their thinking
if my momma said it my daddy said that
my grandmother said it it must be true
therefore and oftentimes people are
ruined as a result of what they have
been taught of what they have been hurt
or what they've heard from someone that
they value very highly that our love and
desire for material things can cause us
to miss the most important thing in life
people don't realize that money is
dangerous somebody says well what could
be dangerous about money it's what it
does it's the attitude people have but
if I have enough money I can go where I
want to go do what I want to do marry
who I want to marry wear what I want to
wear drive want to want to drive live
where I want to live eat where I want to
eat and on and on and on and go
that maybe some of the things that money
can do but that isn't satisfying but
think about this you can have all the
money in the world you want if you don't
you have good health you can buy it if
you not listening if you don't have
anybody to love you can buy it if you
don't have anyone who loves you you can
buy it that was you know you can't buy
peace joy happiness contentment and you
certainly cannot buy eternal life money
can do some things we can do many good
things in the right hands but it can't
satisfy the longing of your soul it
can't satisfy the longing of your heart
and when I think about the future not
thinking about all the possibilities and
living in this age of electronics and we
can learn so much in all the
informations right there fingertips and
the opportunities we have I would hate
to think I'd reach my full potential no
I don't think you should ever live to
the point you think well I've reached it
now then what do you do you just die and
I think many people die early because
they limit what their potential is keep
learning when you cease to learn you
cease to grow when you cease to learn
you sort of begin to decay a little bit
you are to learn how to stay healthy and
you say well how do I do that it will
the proper diet and exercise and rest
that's part of it there was we're not
healthy by accident it's by learning
some key things in life that really make
a difference and when we keep learning
something happens in a life for example
you're not living in an age when we've
had to keep learning because when I was
born there were no computers that I knew
of in 1932 so we go back and you look at
your life and think about all the things
that you've had to learn that your
predecessors and your parents didn't
have to learn because they didn't even
exist
so if you're going to be useful all the
days of your life you've got to be
willing to keep learning so I would
simply say that a lazy brain is an aging
brain you don't want to learn what
happens you start decaying and so
there's something interesting and
exciting about learning things in life
no matter who you are and no matter what
your age might be projection is probably
the most painful of all the emotions and
the truth is all of us have been
rejected Eve about somebody or some
group or something at some point in life
and so the question is how did you
respond and if I should ask you well did
that rejection bother you do you ever
think about it no it doesn't bother me
and never think about it much
but let me just correct that it does
bother you until the person recognizes
the presence of rejection in their life
and discovers the source of it and deals
with it it will bother you all of your
life let's just say for a moment and in
clarify what we mean by rejection and
the truth is if somebody rejects
something that means they refuse it if
you come to me and say I'd like to be
your friend
and I reject you what I'm saying is I
don't want to be your friend I refuse
your offer of friendship and what does
that do that causes the other person to
feel less respect for themselves less
worthy themselves and to begin to be
self-critical for the simple reason why
wouldn't somebody want to be my friend
and so there are some basic things that
a very basic when it comes to to that
and what it does it sends a message
in other words rejection isn't just the
feeling it sends a message when you
reject somebody you send them a strong
message going straight to the core of
their heart you're not worthy you're not
fit you don't belong I don't want you
you don't fit into this situation
anytime anybody feels that it's
specially different from somebody that's
very precious of them are very important
to them it's devastating if you don't
feel rejected if you're not careful
you'll reject somebody else
but more than likely all of us that some
point have been and what I want to show
you is this just because you think you
have forgotten it doesn't mean that you
don't still have it the question is what
do you do with it how do you have it
and the lots of ways people handle
rejection that doesn't free them of it
what I want to talk about is how you get
free of it
there is a way to overcome that no
matter what it is there are three there
are three feelings that are absolutely
essential to a healthy self attitude and
a self your own personal view of
yourself the self respect and everything
else these three attitudes are a sense
of belonging I belong at very important
to be a part I'm a part of the second
one is I'm worthy that is you know what
I'm worth something imabelle you god
loves me
and thirdly I'm competent I can do it I
can handle it whatever it is if you
don't have those three feelings about
yourself emotions about yourself you go
through life suffering and hurting
healthy body a healthy body is always
important for the separation you feel
better you Mahalo motivated you want
cheerful you're happy you're excited and
people like to be around the person like
that and then I think about our
relationships two of us without good
relationships to other people you're not
going to make it in life where we're not
lone Ranger's God's made us to work in
labor and fellowship and have fun with
other people why would a city known
towards red economy over all these years
you'll bankrupt
while do you bankrupt unwise decisions
that probably started years before why
would a family choose to buy a home
house that they know that they cannot
afford but they going to buy anyway
unwise decision why would a person marry
just for sexual fulfillment not thinking
about other things unwise decision why
would a person drink alcoholic beverage
spent in front of their children early
in life leaving them an image of their
dad sometimes being drunk taking nothing
of a consequence very unwise decision
when you think about the kind of your
life that you're living would you say
that the decisions that you're making a
wise or unwise and we can go through
life thinking about all the decisions
that people make for example they stack
up credit on their credit cards to the
point that they know they can't make the
payments what a bit is that unwise
decisions before you make a decision you
should always ask this question is this
is this the wisest thing to do
there is always an answer is this the
wisest thing to do whether it's marriage
or whether something financial or health
or whatever it might be is this the
wisest thing to do that's always the
right question whether it's major or
minor is this the wisest thing to do but
living wisely is the best life wisdom is
a gift from God
living unwisely is a very expensive
lifestyle to every aspect of a life when
there's laughter and as love and there's
joy your body is going to respond
accordingly but if you're uptight
and you're not laughing
and if you just think about what happens
to your whole nervous system when you
can't laugh and somebody's Israel I
don't have anything to laugh about well
yes you do if you think about it you do
there are times we don't feel like
laughing if you can't laugh I'm not too
sure you've got many friends who wants
to be around a grouch all the time
always frowning there's always something
wrong and when you say let me tell you
something good happen to me I'm not
interested well when people have that
attitude I believe your nervous system
is affected your whole system is
affected I think there's some simple
things God placed in our life and the
process of exercising them will live
longer
now you say can you prove that or so far
I can so far I can and and one of the
things I love about my friends is we are
always getting each other and one of my
friends and all I think all of a sudden
you this one not all my friends but we
are always jabbing each other but some
we're always laughing and I think that
frees up your nervous system something
happens when you're laughing so if
you're going to be useful all the days
of your life you not only have to be
learning and loving but laughing so you
may say well I don't have any laugh
about we'll make something get something
going and watch something that will help
you laugh
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because in the bowmen
asked me to if there's someone you like
in a profile in the next top 10 check
out the link in the description and go
and cast your vote I'd also love to know
what was your favourite message from
this video what did you learn from this
video that you're going to immediately
apply somehow in your life or in your
business please leave it down the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to telly Quinton Kelly thank
you so much for picking up 10 copies of
my book your one word and sending them
out to your friends I hope you and they
really enjoyed the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love amazing
[Music]